what's up game spotters this is aaron
Sampson with a recap of the ARMA 3
episode 1 survive episode 1 survive
kicks off with the newscast that's all
NATO peacekeeping is over oh [ __ ] it
didn't work you do an on-rails walking
sequence and then sit in a helicopter
with your pants off you drive a truck
and they're all like oh [ __ ] it's a dead
guy what leap does he have he's a
commander or something then it's all
like oh [ __ ] locals don't like us get
some Rogaine which I'm not really sure
what male pattern baldness has to do
with anything at this point so you go
all Blair Witch running through the
woods and Sergeant Adam steps on a land
mine and gets all dead and has some
decent loot fast forward your base it's
all destroyed and crap so get to the
chopper but the chopper gets all blown
up and you shoot dudes and hills and
then instead of get to the chopper it's
get to the regroup point more running
through the woods more regrouping on
Rails walking again welcome to camp
Maxwell dudes all organized go to the
chopper that is shot down on the
hillside over here you get there and
there's a wounded pilot but he doesn't
have any cool loot for some reason the
enemy forces want him anyway so you kill
their asses and you finally find some
good loot blow the chopper back to base
Miller's all blah blah blah scoop
insertion you take off your pants and
find you're wearing a man suit go jacket
under water and all of your buddies made
to the beach before you because they
have pants kill some officer and find
some good loot a rocket oh crap you
killed the wrong officer find a longneck
bug go for a drive miller runs his
yapper again and then you go do the
challenge mission that you did it
launched which includes failing to get a
drone off the ground because ARMA and go
off to take care of some spotters
yourself moving on you call in artillery
strike on an enemy base and your team is
like get back in the vehicle idiots but
to ignore them and shoot up the bass
solo because that's how you roll clean
up some reinforcements and blow up a
giant nerd on the hillside then you find
out there's more chapters so you go play
wasteland mod into leather play
dude get away from wait who's stealing
my [ __ ] truck dude we need the i7i
sweaty penis